we understand that you fell off a ladder
while painting something like that yeah
I am well let me let me talk about how
we got into between us so because this
kind of leads into it a little bit so
hopefully I can fit it in a one card so
I had done my last movie which was
called open house which is your real
estate musical because someone had to
make one and it's a former realtor I
hope you appreciate that and anyway
there was talk of turning it into we had
done a crazy oscar campaign which was
the whole other story but there was talk
of turning the movie into a stage play
Broadway off-broadway or something and
the Weinsteins own the rights to it at
the time they were interested in it so I
went out to New York for a couple trips
and started meeting with with theater
people agents and producers and anyone i
could find with jazz hands in New York
and and anyway but while I was in the
room I said look as long as I'm here do
you guys have any stage plays not
necessarily musicals but plays that
would make good film adaptations and
they're like yeah no one ever asked us
for these here stacks and stacks of
place and I was like wow cool so I
started reading these plays and you know
I had like 30 that I read there are
really only two that I liked that I
really gravitated and thought I could
adapt one was between us the other was
at the time called farragut north it was
kind of a political thriller and I'd
worked in politics before so I kind of
liked it but I thought it would be
difficult to adapt on a low budget if I
had to do it as opposed to between us
which is four people in two rooms how
hard could that be and so as I passed on
that one and of course George Clooney
turns out into hides of March and he
gets a happy ending for my sloppy
seconds on that but um but with between
us I thought okay this is something i
could really you know sink my teeth into
and it kind of fit with where I was
going where I wasn't in my life dealing
with the you know marriage I mean I have
good marriage it's not horrible like the
people in the movie but um you know and
kids and financial issues and things
like a so I could kind of relate to it
born and in the original play
the whole first act set in the
Midwestern house and the second act to
set two years later in a New York
apartment and so I had the idea that to
adapt it we would kind of intertwine
those together and kind of flash forward
and flashback and so I approached johor
two of the playwright and between us had
been a very successful hit play
off-broadway play at manhattan theatre
club in New York and and Joe was was
very amenable to having it turned into a
feature and he really liked my idea and
Joe and I got along well together and so
we took that as the underlying approach
to doing the adaptation but then I still
there were a few other elements that I
wanted to kind of insert more of my own
life into so about nine months before
I'd even read this play I had we've been
renovating my house to her and well
we're in the garage here and towards the
end of the renovation I fell off a
ladder and snapped my leg my leg I
caught the wrongs that snapped off and
my bones came out and I lost forty
percent of my blood I broke my shoulder
it was I was in a wheelchair for about
six months and crutches for another six
months and a cane and you know for
another six months and then then I broke
my like a second time at the US comedy
arts festival in Aspen because well it's
a comedy festival so if you get a slip
on the ice you may as well do it there
that time wasn't as bad but still had to
have surgery again for that so anyway so
this experience was rather fresh in my
head when I was reading the script and
reading the original play and one of the
characters Joel who's played by david
harbor in the film and actually the
original play at one point he's talking
about having gone through a catharsis
and it's done because it's clay it's
done in monologue there's no flashbacks
you can't show him you know do this
moment and and so I felt like we needed
because it's a film there are certain
things you need to show I mean everyone
always says how are you going to open up
a play and really what they're saying is
how are you going to make it more
cinematic and so you do that by
editorially you can jump forward and
backwards by location move to different
locations
also by moving the camera in and out of
things so this is an example where I
wanted to show what this character had
gone through and so and so I decided I
said well look it's a little
narcissistic but I always say write what
you know so I said why don't we just
have the guy have virtually the exact
same accident that I had he falls off a
ladder snaps his leg off and he's in a
wheelchair and and and it it helped
explain a few other issues in the story
about why his wife would accept him and
why he goes through this kind of
catharsis that he'd go that the
character goes through because having
gone through and he has kind of a sort
of a small as spiritual change which
never happened to me but I can it made a
lot more sense to me having gone through
that experience that oh ok if you're
hopped up on vicodin and you're going
through this whole thing it can really
change your whole perspective it can
change your relationship with your
spouse for better or for worse and you
know and and so that explained it made
it easier for me to kind of get into the
script and make it personal for me which
i think is good when you're adapting
something to you you need to find
something in there to latch onto
yourself otherwise at some point it's
going to get driven crazy and just give
up on it so and then visually also when
I had my accident like I was almost out
of the wheelchair and I was in park city
that year at Slamdance and when you're
in the snow people would take pictures
of me and I thought oh well I've never
seen a wheelchair in the snow and
there's a reason for it it's really hard
to manipulate a wheelchair in the snow
people who do regularly have them have
snow tires or mountain bike wheels that
they put on the wheelchair but regularly
you wouldn't think to do that and and I
just kind of and this before i read the
play so i just kind of bank that image
ok wheelchair in the snow like that's
cool maybe i'll use that at some point
and yeah yeah so there is so there you
go so that that I kind of brought into
it strain it now that I'm thinking about
it actually was kind of suggested a
little bit by The Washington Post gossip
columnist why not because that year I
was in the wheelchair and I got pulled
over by for highway patrolman nearly
arrested
going through the wendys in the
drive-thru because I said it was a
drive-thru and not a walkthrough and I
said well I'm rolling I'm not walking
anyway so they tried to arrest me got
the Washington Post because otherwise
what's the point of doing anything and
it was actually in in the interview or
maybe in the story amy argetsinger the
gossip columnist says you know I
speculate though maybe this is research
for for a part in his next movie or
something and I think I told her oh no
it's it's not you know but then it was
about three months later that I read the
script I was like oh you know that's not
a bad idea you know maybe I should put
in a movie so I owe I owe her my thanks
wow so she had a premonition yes and you
have a very powerful wheelchair scene in
the film and I know that there's a whole
backstory in terms of the lugging gear
up a mountain right and and all that but
how are you infusing that mood into your
actor at that moment and I understand it
was cold and you were you know yeah we
all sign to get that shot because it was
in April and there was no snow in
Nebraska we and we have planned to fly
out to Nebraska and shoot that shot then
and it just got the schedule got pushed
back a little bit so we were going to
shoot in in Nebraska but there was no
snow in Nebraska them so they'll one
place we could find snow in America
pretty much was outside of LA but now in
North Valley there's this mountain
called Mount pinas it's about eight or
nine of us when it drove too close to
the summit of the mountain had been 400
pounds of equipment plus a wheelchair
and hiked for about an hour up to the
summit of the mountain and I go I know
this mountain well because I go sledding
with my kids and so I knew that I knew
that there would be a clearing at the
top and it's and you know a tree on one
side and tree on the other side but
there's no horizon because you're at
eighty six hundred feet and just drops
for hundreds of miles because it's
California and so if you put the camera
in the right way it looks like flat
Nebraska planes so once we hiked up
there and people were like are we there
yet are we there yet are we and I was
like we're all was there we're almost
there were almost there because the
trail isn't marked at all so people had
no idea that I knew what the hell I was
doing they really went on faith and yeah
so no and David Harbor he who plays the
character who does this
he'd been in the original play so you
know he's a good actor and he was cold
and frustrated and I say so that came
out yeah yeah no I mean his he was bar
he didn't bring his own boots he was
borrowing an old pair of my boots and
they split open about 50 feet up the
hike we had to wrap them together in
gaffers tape I say so yeah it was a
challenging experience but we all
survived and we got the shot and then
once we got there people are like oh
that's the shot okay right yeah its
people shot yeah I just worth it um it
worked
you